YO GUYS!
DickbagMc-
DickSucker here! With another
WACKY ZAPPY LET'S PLAY
Welcum bak 2 Mario Maker guyz!
[italian voice] Oh No! Not a this a loser!
FFFFFEEED MY NIPPLES!
If I can beat this, I would be un-
Why?
Why that not...?
No...
Efthsss stupid...
Oh come on...
... with this...!
Get outta my way...!
WOAGH!
STOP IT!
STOOOOOOP!
JUST STOOOOP!
OOOOOH GOOOOOOOOD DAMMIT!
Uuugh... ffffrack...
Stoooooop!
Eugh, goddamnit,  finally.
NO!
Fuck you!
W- Wh- Why?
Why?
He's - ugh, fuck.
Do it. I - fuckin' do it!
FUCKIN'-
FUCK!
I am the ja-ha ha it's fun for you!
GUESS WHO IT'S NOT FUN FOR!
So if I fall in the fire, I will eat my own eyeball. [ew]
Okay, so if I put this here, he shouldn't bou-woah.
OOOAAAAAAAGH!
OOOOOHHHH NOOO! WHAT THE BOLOGNA?! [yumm]
I forgot!
AAAAGGGH! I had that!
Okay.
Fuck!
OH GOD!
WOAH GOD!
[screaming like markimoo always does]
[outro incoming]
Oh god should I be-should I be doing this?
Oh Oh!
AHHH...WHAT?...NO...!WHAT WAS THAT?
OOHHHHHH!
HOW WAS THAT?!
I DIDN'T!...HOW DID IT PUSH ME BACK?!
I DON'T WE BOOSH'D!
I DON'T B-BOOSH!
THAT'S A BUNCH OF BUSHY DOUCHEY!